bonjour je vous donne rendez-vous cette
semaine pour un nouveau numéro de fil
échos au programme de cette édition la
pose de la première pierre de l'entrée
du quartier de villas roi guyancourt ce
projet a été distingué par un prix une
pyramide d'argent un chantier qui
s'étend sur plus de vingt mille mètres
carrés et comprend des logements
commerces et services vous allez le
découvrir dans notre entretien de la
semaine nous parlerons de la pépinière
d'entreprises de versailles grand parc
et de ses dynamiques et initiatives
enfin dans notre partie magazine nous
vous emmenons chez un apiculteur à
plaisir mais aussi dans le premier bar à
sirops des yvelines situé à chevreuse il
est tenu par un sirop pied qui fabrique
lui même et de façon artisanale tous ces
produits tout ce reportage vous le
retrouverez cette semaine à 10h30
d'enfiler go